we're good good to go
ash in the clams ash in the clam strips
yeah we're late [ __ ] off
we're not supposed to smoke in the room
yeah
let me tell you something right now
after the service i've gotten at this
place
they're lucky this is all i'm doing
we're here at the win
well they can use this against us can't
they if we say where we are
i'll bleep it out we're at the encore in
uh everett massachusetts
it's [ __ ] dump we're here because
texas has been destroyed
by snow uh
god only knows what joe rogan and elon
musk are doing down there [ __ ] around
getting everybody to move down there and
then the whole state's
belly up because there's ice and then i
have my dirtbag family texting me going
you need anything
yeah i need a storm to hit you you know
damn well
this is what i love during the tragedy
you know damn well you can't do anything
for me
this is when peop by the way people
never ask you if you need anything in a
non-tragedy
when you might actually need something
they only ask you if you need something
when they know they can't feasibly get
you
fly here yeah i need something uh are
you on the way
come we got rolling blackouts and the
water's [ __ ]
are you coming what do you think i'm
gonna ask for heated blanket you dumb
[ __ ]
there's nothing to for you to do except
send a
text do you need something which is the
biggest
hollow gesture in the world michelle was
doing that all day do you need anything
do you need something is there anything
i can do
do you need do you do you are you okay
and if i'm not
then what what are you gonna do
are you gonna be bothered by that well
we feel so sad for
you i feel so bad
is there anything that you need yes the
state needs a water treatment facility
immediately
will you start on that we need the roads
cleared
are you going to get involved with the
clearing of the roads or is this
fake do you need something yes i'd like
a natural disaster to hit
you as well that's true i i would want
more pain to be equally spread out
through the country
if i had my druthers
oh do you need help my cousin texts me i
respect that she goes are you still
going to be in providence we'd like
tickets
i'll read now i'll read it i mean these
peop you can't cr
you can't create these people you
couldn't create these people if you were
trying
uh they go uh listen to this i love this
and i love her she's a good woman but uh
this is
my favorite here they go hey by the way
are you
are you still like hope everything's
okay
i'm trying to find this one it was like
i i was like completely stunned by this
but not
surprised which is most of my
interactions
you know i'm not i'm not surprised by
this at all
hey hope you're surviving the snow
like people being rolled into the street
people die it's like
people are dead people are freezing to
death people are freezing to death they
haven't had [ __ ]
and don't if you work at the hotel use
this as proof that we smoked in a room
don't do that hey hope you're surviving
the snow
hopefully the snow will be gone in time
for your providence shows
we would love to do the monday or
tuesday 7 p.m if either is better for
you
will you have any down time in the
schedule to hang
at that point i was eating a fish stick
in the darkness of my house
that was cold i was eating a cold fish
stick with dan
on the floor praying for uh
the mercy of god and they're gone by the
way what's date works better for the
free
tickets monday or tuesday which date is
better for the free tickets
i hope you're surviving the snow
i hope the abominable snowman didn't get
you
everyone who grows up in long island
never truly leaves in their mind
it's all about you know it's all about
them and that's fine
but that's okay you were in la [ __ ]
uh you know doing nothing
well we all burned in hell you're mr
texas yep your family has no power i
have no power and
you're [ __ ] sitting there you and
your wife eating sushi and playing golf
like you're having a grand old time
texting everybody my agent's trying to
get me to my agent by the way
this guy they're not flying planes he
goes
why why don't why doesn't he take a
charter flight for fifteen thousand
dollars
what he goes just take a charter flight
so what it crashes
we'll sue for the commission so what he
dies
this is this is the way these people
think take a charter flight for eighteen
thousand dollars
doesn't matter you don't make any money
i make the same commission what's the
worst that happens you skid off the
runway and break your neck
who cares you incinerate now go up in a
ball of flames
i don't care i'll hear about it at
maestros and tweet r.i.p
and then sue the club for the commission
that's okay with a team like this
sky's the limit i mean
it's truly it was truly rough there
and you get cravings when you're young
you know you get because
it reminds you of a snow day the first
day is fun it's like a snow day and you
go
it'll be a fun day because i haven't
seen snow in a while i've been out in
l.a
we go it'll be fun and then
day two you go this is wacky
and day three you go this is a problem
nothing was open gas stations were not
open
fast food was not open uh
whataburger opened on the second day but
it was like an hour and a half line like
there was nothing going on
and people were starving and they had no
water and thank god my water was okay
but closer to austin they didn't have
any water
and uh people had to boil their water
and they had no electricity to boil
their own water
you know boiling water they're still
boiling their own water i mean people
are boiling their own piss to drink
and ted cruz is going down to mexico to
do cocaine with the cartel
and his daughters ray comp had a great
tweet they go he goes hey maybe ted
cruz's daughter's killed a guy
maybe they're just trying to get out of
there do you ever think about that
but yeah i mean it was it was rough and
so wheat me and dan went i'll tell you
right now when you
shop in in a in a blizzard nobody wants
a salad like when you go
shopping in a blizzard you go hard and
we're in texas and i mean let me tell
you right now
the milk was gone like pancake batter
was running low
but uh vegetables were available like ev
you could get as much spinach or lettuce
as you want
you you wanted a tomato you could get
one but
uh all the like frozen food was sold out
and everyone knew this wasn't gonna go
on it was like already over by the way
on the third day
everyone knew was gonna end on the next
day and people were still like
we need red baron pizzas for three years
everyone knew it was done it's like why
don't you have a salad
cleanse yourself people i don't think so
i need 18
white castle slatters this may never end
i'm like the sun's out it's literally
melting
we were in the grocery store it's
literally melting people just buying
buckets of food and walking out i'm like
this is a you thing this has nothing to
do with the storm at this point
it's literally over you know it's it's
literally done so we're hearing
the wind in everett massachusetts a good
goddamn dump
well it's the encore it's not the win
it's the encore boston harbor
imagine the people that go to a casino
in february uh during a pandemic or
whatever's left in the pandemic
to just enjoy uh and by the way
they're militant here about who can be
in the elevators yeah and how many
people could be in a room if there's
there's four people in a room and if
there's a fifth one it's a
two thousand dollar fine and they
enforce the uh
elevators how many people could go in
the elevator how many people can go
what is the point of any of this what is
four people in the elevator no one gets
cold
that's not it what virologist designed
this
just you gotta dance four feet away from
someone in mystique nightclub
i mean it's a real it's a [ __ ] show here
people are taking the last of their
of the checks the last of whatever
stimulus money they have
and they're going and just trying to win
big because amc didn't pan out i lost
and uh you know people are people are
hurting so they came here to the
original casino to just
you know let's see what happens and uh
i mean casino people we've talked about
it on the show it's not
good uh but i mean it's just tough here
it's tough here to watch just cold
like hardened massachusetts people
trying their luck and then the young
kids like the young pale
white gaunt heroine addicts just kind of
like
with tattoos just wandering around
because there's nothing worse than young
people at a casino
i've said that before anybody you see an
old person in casino you go we get it
it's almost over you're like maybe
but it's real rough to watch a 21 year
old be like let's go
scary that's all you got it's all you
got it's up
you're 20 and you think it's about luck
you're like all right i'm 23.
let's see what we got that's a real big
problem but it's fine
everything's gonna be a-okay kendall
jenner
is getting a lot of [ __ ] for this i
don't know if the 818 tequila well
it's not even that it's kendall jenner
cultural appropriation has just
released a new line of slaves
and people are very upset now these are
haitian slaves
that the the jenner family has bought
the kardashian family
they bought 300 haitian slaves and
they're selling them on the open market
and people are angry about this
i don't get it but they're very angry
because they think that she's culturally
appropriating
or she shouldn't be a slave trader and
what she's doing
is it's it's a new line of slaves
um who are being treated very well
i mean this is from everything i'm
hearing they're being treated incredibly
well
they have uh health checkups and
stylists and everything like that
and she doesn't like the term slaves
she's calling them helpers
and a lot of people are getting angry at
her and i think it's unfair and i just
don't like cancel culture
i think canceled culture's got to stop
cancel culture's got to stop if a young
talented woman like kendall jenner
cannot go to haiti
and buy 300 slaves on the open market
and then sell them or libya i forget
which one but i think it's both they've
got deals different places
different suppliers she's very smart
about business
she's very smart about business this
woman and nobody
respects it and people are jealous of
her
because they didn't think to go buy
slaves
it is a smart investment
human trafficking is a major business
she's no idiot
she's no fool and people are mad at her
and it's like uh enough with the cancer
culture
stop shaming her because she's a
businesswoman
and literally and figure figuratively
wants to crack the whip
what's the big deal she's got a few
hundred slaves on the open market
no what is this tequila it's really
tequila is it slaves
i don't even know anymore i don't even
know what's a joke anymore or what's not
a joke
it's not slaves it's tequila
and people are mad at her because why
because it's mexican
because it's the area code 818 and you
know the valley yeah the valley and it's
a pro well they live in a valley
yeah they live in calabasas which i
don't really have nobody really
right nobody thinks of that they don't
think of calabasas when they think of
the valley
but so she's appropriating the area code
yeah and it's also like it's mexican
territory because you know they've
worked really hard to have tequila
brands but
people have pointed out that george
clooney and all these other big
celebrities have tequila companies too
so yeah there's not a ton of mexicans
with tequila companies my maid does not
own a tequila company
from what i understand she's drunk on
tequila and doesn't do any work
but she i don't think she owns the
company by the way i'm not saying all
mexicans are maids either but you know
what i mean
she is my maids are made she ain't a
good one
so the problem is that we max what is
the problem
she's appropriating like jalisco
is the city where apparently they create
a lot of the tequila
yeah it's been like hundreds of years
these families have been
you know making these tequila companies
and been working very hard on them and
she just sort of trots in
and says this is just kendall just get
slaves
if they're gonna get mad at you anyway
just
get slaves
i mean i wanna the next time people come
at these two girls
i wanna see them doing a slave auction
in the middle of beverly hills
with libyan slaves
they're gonna get mad anyway
i don't know if there's this is a
problem jalisco is where they make the
tequila
that's what i was reading yeah kendall's
the loser kylie's the billionaire
kendall's got nothing going on so she's
just trying to
wet her beak with a little tequila
she should just lean in and start
selling [ __ ]
taco kits old el paso should [ __ ]
partner with kendall jenner
kendall jenner should become every
everything mexican
like just lean in start
just open up a trendy arepas restaurant
which are venezuelan but whatever it's
late
um but that's what she should do she
should call tacos by kendall
tacos by kendall she should just say
[ __ ] it
i'm gonna sell mexican [ __ ] who cares
like this person was mad on twitter they
said tired of the celebrity tequila
craze
wtf does kendall jenner know about
tequila my family's been doing
back-breaking work in fields for their
entire lives in jalisco just for people
to come here's what kendall jenner knows
about the kids she knows is drinking it
and getting in a range rover and driving
home and not getting caught
she knows about consuming it she knows
about taking a few
shots of it and falling into a [ __ ]
escalade
that's what she knows about it she knows
about drinking a lot of it and then
going and sucking off a rapper
it's alcohol stop making it into like a
spiritual thing it's booze
right isn't it booze
what does this woman work she's never
worked in a field you're on twitter
you're in the field you're on twitter
what field are you in you can take time
to tweet
i see people in the fields none of them
have a phone
what did she take the phone out she's in
the field going my family
you know what they would say they go get
the [ __ ] work
i am taking it to kendall jenner
i am i'm wrecking kendall jenner
get get your [ __ ] hands on the crop
but i must no hold
on i am sending a tweet
who's this with the tweet this is our
last episode on youtube
i'm gonna burn this hotel down here i
ordered a spoon an hour ago it's not
here she doesn't look like she works in
the fields i'll turn this around for you
the fields
the fields yeah she lives in l.a
i'm not saying people shouldn't be
pissed about this but the people that
should be pissed at this are working
right they're in trouble
they're not concerned about kendall
jenner trying to do want someone to let
him out of a cage
i mean so what is the whole tweet i
didn't even
oh tired of celebrity tequila craze wtf
does kendall jenner know about tequila
my family's been doing back breaking
work in the fields for their entire
lives in jalisco just for people to come
dip their toes stay in your lane
stay in your lane yeah i'll start a
mexican tequila company
so what and she's this other person says
she's not to mention she's profiting off
the brown hands that actually plant grow
harvest ferment and distill
everything but that's everyone's the
hands of
everything yeah
i've got no love loss for uh
who are they again the kardashian i
don't care about these people
and they don't they don't factor into my
life at all but to just get mad at them
and not get mad at everybody else who's
profiting off the brown hands in the
fields
right right now you're right so many
people have
uh tequila companies george clooney
right yeah
clooney
oj should start a liquor company
o.j should start a booze company
he's black he's loud yeah who cares
hey [ __ ] are you a fat [ __ ] and you
don't want to be a fat
[ __ ] anymore you're a disgusting pig and
you want to kill yourself every time you
look at yourself
open up your phone look at a picture
from you 15 years ago
and gaze at the face in that bathroom
mirror chances are it doesn't look good
and it feels worse
go to massive produced mass if 10 day
fasting smash and greens integrity and
accountability challenge i bet you won't
[ __ ]
go to massivesupplements.com and check
this out right now they have come up
with unique challenges where the average
weight loss is 15 pounds in 10 days
though it doesn't end there if you
complete both the integrity and
accountability challenges
they'll even pay you 500 cash which you
can use for bail when the cops come to
your house
after you've been accused of domestic
violence all you have to do is lose
weight don't be a [ __ ] mindset is
everything those are actual quotes from
the program
your wife fell down the stairs she's she
didn't hit her
she's always running her mouth this is
how it works during the last 10 days you
were on a fast except for the
supplements
vitamins and shake made with massive
signature meal replacement
the smash and greens they're an
extremely nutrient-dense blend of
organic superfoods with no fillers
and if anybody if anybody says why are
you not eating say because i don't want
to be a
[ __ ] pig anymore like you
is who cares your mother goes tell your
fat mother and father that
the ingredients were specifically chosen
to macromize macro
maximize micronutrients curb hunger
maximum energy clear skin and burn fat
this stuff works creator mitch aguiar is
a former navy seal and current
professional mma fighter and psychopath
he created smash and greens as a way to
cut down in weight classes for
professional fighters
while maintaining performance and
nutrition use the same tools as the pros
you have no excuse
mitch believes in violence first
massive also has every top-notch
supplement you can ever need they have
pre-workout gain multivitamin creatine
a wide array of protein shakes and even
incredible coffee krista stefano was a
daily drinker of massive coffee
and he said they got him so jacked up
and played a part in the dissolution of
history hyenas
massive also sent me a box of the
products i was talking about i of course
tried everything especially love the
shirt i received that said defund the
media
those are also for sale at
massivesupplements.com
this is for q and on people that want to
get in better shape so they can storm
the capital next year
so what are you waiting for lose the
weight visit massivesupplements.com and
use a promo code tim d
for 10 off all orders across the site
that's masfsupplements.com and user
promo code timdy
10 off all orders across the site don't
be a [ __ ]
this episode is sponsored by bluetooth
say with this bluetooth it's making
waves and bringing more confidence to
the bedroom by offering chewable tablets
that can help men get stronger and
longer lasting erections
bluetooth's unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost
bluetooth tablets help men achieve
harder stronger erections to combat all
forms of erectile dysfunction
bluetooth is an online prescription
service no visits to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations no waiting in
line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet package go to bluetrue.com
for more details important safety
information etc once you're approved
you'll receive prescription within days
the best part
it's all done online blue chews licensed
medical providers work with you to find
the right ingredient and strength of
your prescription
don't like swallowing pills no problems
here blue chews
sladenophyll and talidanophil tablets
are chewable
they're made in the usa and they prepare
you and ship direct it's cheaper than a
pharmacy go to bluechew.com
promo code td first month free
bluetooth.com promo code td first month
free
a woody allen doc i hear is gonna be a
real barn burner
not good
not not not good
i don't know what to believe because
he's a brilliant filmmaker
but the movies all do have a theme don't
they have a theme
the films i mean there's many themes
there's some of my favorite movies ever
but he does seem very focused on the
young
ladies now this documentary is
supposedly so
harrowing it's very troubling they have
uh
adam curtis's new dock i got a watch
everybody loves it
can't get you out of my head or
something yes everybody loves it
anacotchia loves it right cump
the whole all the intellectuals uh
now this woody allen dock is on hbo
yeah it's called allen versus pharaoh
and supposedly the most disturbing part
of this
is um a scene
where he where the dylan is young
seven not good and
she starts a tequila company no she
she claims he abused her on camera yeah
and people are saying mia pharah might
have coached that but then there's a lot
of people that say man it's pretty
[ __ ] damning when you see a
seven-year-old kid
you couldn't get me to say anything
really at seven that i wasn't
truly you know i don't know
can you get a kid to say so i'm sure you
could
i'm sure people but i mean it's just
very sad
to think about obviously someone getting
abused in that way which is horrible and
then it's
also very sad to think about
i mean it's just not helped by the fact
that he married his stepdaughter
and what's interesting about him is he
does strike me as a sociopathic you
never see him sad
in an interview and he never seemed that
happy he's kind of just very even
keeling hell this is what we do
we make a picture every year and uh we
do it in new york and
you know it got a little too pricey in
new york so now we shoot other places
and
i write every day like every interview
is like i get up and i write every day
in this little moleskine
notebook and i and i rape my uh child
that's what i do i write in the
moleskine notebook and uh
i rate my kid it feels
i don't know i mean gun gun in the head
ben got in the head
is this guy guilty do you think woody
allen
was uh because pharaoh said she found
porn kid porn the
pictures of the i know when they were
married that he wanted to live in
separate houses
but just for his own work so he could
keep working on movies that seems like a
guy that would want the kids by
himself so it's a red flag right
right it's a red flag but the
kardashians all live in separate houses
that's true because they're buying
slaves
but what why would this we're delirious
at this point folks been up 16 hours
should woody allen marry kendall jenner
what if what if what if
woody allen married kendall jenner
and they and they just started a
tequila empire yeah what is the
now woody allen married his stepdaughter
suny previn
and who was cool about it yeah that's
that's kind of
ballsy yeah to go this is my [ __ ]
and i used to raise her but now i [ __ ]
her
and that's the facts i didn't make that
up this is literally what happened
and if you have a problem with that [ __ ]
off yeah
and polite society was like okay all
right
odd the heart wants what it wants yeah
yeah that's what he said he said
something like artists create their own
moral universe
something like that yeah i mean so this
document when does this documentary drop
i think pretty soon and then it's kind
of all over for him
well i don't think there's a ton going
on now i think he's pretty much in the
de numa
of it yeah is there a trailer
i don't believe so you can't play in any
way oh yeah that's right because hbo
i'm saddened by this because i like
woody allen but i don't like
uh him raping the kids
i think woody defenders always say they
go well he didn't actually raise her
someone else like raised her and he
never really had any contact with her
can i can i throw out a thing that heals
this sure sure
woody allen rapes kendall jenner
as of to for healing
as a way to heal can he get out of the
dog house
crystalia came back out and we like
chris and you know chris had to
she said he had a sex addiction and
there's he's but every relationship was
legal and consensual and
we have always said on the show that
there's real no evidence or proof
of his
guilt that was satisfactory to anyone
there was no evidence or proof of his
kill
and yet he lost everything because of it
so i think that's a problem
in society i do i mean if i'm an only
child
if i had a little sister i wouldn't be
like here's chris you know i wouldn't be
like let's meet him
that wouldn't be the first thing i would
do right but still
that's okay that's still not killed
right
i mean so my my
my situation with all these things is
like
i mean should true dylan farrow
just say hey
it's tough because she's had this
horrible thing happen to her
and ronan farrow
is supportive dylan but he's a liar
and mia farrow is the one who
people woody says has orchestrated this
entire thing
it's a tough situation to be in
you know for everyone involved and
i i would have dylan farrow on the show
yeah and i will offer that dylan take a
look at this
take a look at this i want a clam strip
dylan i have one dylan i tell you right
now
if you want to tell a tale we want to
tell a tale
if you want to tell a tale whether it's
true or not you come right on a program
i don't care what you say
and that goes for kendall jenner you
want to come in here and tell people
about slavery
you do it this is the new set for the
show by the way
hope everyone likes it what
is
let's ask a few questions that are not
popular sure
if you are a brilliant artist
like woody allen
should you be allowed
truly if you're a brilliant artist like
woody allen
should you be allowed and this is going
to be very controversial
if you are as talented as he is
should you be allowed to start a tequila
company
you didn't think i was going to do the
other thing did you it's not that late
because you can't you cannot rape the
kids woody
don't do it
but don't you understand this is how the
[ __ ]
this is how every movie that we see now
we're gonna have to look at with
different eyes
all those movies where he was having sex
with high school girls they're gonna
seem wrong now
don't you see that don't you see the
problem here
all those movies where he was 45 and
sniffing the seats if
16 year old girls we're gonna seem odd
now now they're gonna seem weird yeah
all those movies about
trapping young impressionable women in
horrible situations
are now in hindsight
going to seem bad
that's what's crazy
now with the kendall jenner this is what
happens because you ever
everything's revision is history now
because everything makes you hindsight
it's 20 20.
now that i've heard the arguments
against the kendall janet tequila i
think maybe the ice camps were wrong
maybe putting kids in cages was wrong
now that i've learned about to work in
the fields with a jalisco to kill us
do you see now i think that woody allen
should not
maybe all of his love interests in those
movies should not have been 14.
see don't you see when you look back
hindsight's 20 20.
see wow we're learning i'm learning
you're learning does he go on the
offensive allen does he come back hard i
mean he wrote that article where he's
like this [ __ ] is lying i don't know
this [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah he still denies he still denies
everything somehow
him and dylan have a better relationship
still than me and my aunt
i'm still less welcome at christmas than
woody
[ __ ] pedophile allen somehow he walks
in they're like well all right
i walk in it's a real big issue i didn't
[ __ ] anybody
what are you talking about i didn't [ __ ]
anyone in this family
but woody he's old he's an old man
and the game is going to be
his legacy because he's done yeah he's
not coming out like a hot new
photo picture movie it's late
i know chalamet and those guys like
backed out of that premiere right
chalamet has no idea what he's doing
right
i have offered chalamet
a public relations course where i would
keep him in a fish tank
and feed him what i thought he deserved
now i was warned and told by my agents
to
quote stop saying those things
and i was told by my lawyer it was not
smart
same thing he said about the airbnb he
goes can you stop this i said
what what are you on the side of judges
i offered chalamet
a pro a program where he would come live
in my home
and he would be kept in a a tank
sort of sensory deprivation
and i would be allowed to instruct him
because
he seems to be confused
is there anyone less interesting than
him by the way is there anyone less
and call me by your name was freaky
army hammer cannibal was [ __ ]
chalamet who was
17. you know what i mean
so that's odd but it was gay so nobody
really cared about it it was in italy
and they do that in italy
they don't give a [ __ ] and everyone's
hot if there was a movie in
philly where i uh to put timothy
chalamet in the back of a ford explorer
nobody in the hollywood foreign press
would be excited about it
okay and that would be a much better
movie if after an eagles game i took
timothy chalamet a wawa and put him on a
[ __ ]
hero and hate him it would be gross
not to me but to the people that like to
call me by
your name where you had a cannibal
running around and who cares that army
hammer eats people
he has fantasies about eating people
when you [ __ ] as much as army hammer
you can't get off
normally you got to imagine eating a
bitch's kidney
you got to imagine taking a kidney and
putting it in your
throat and good but it's hypocrisy
because if call me by your name was
about me
and chalamet which is what it should
have been about and i was
gonna be in a movie they were i was
gonna be in a
film and we can't talk about it because
we signed an nda
but i only signed das disclose all
but i i like the director
as a person i mean i don't know his work
he's done great things and he's a good
person
and he tried hard to get us me in the
movie
and then then he gave it to another job
as someone else who is fatter and older
and a better actor
you know but this is the problem when
you act it's so [ __ ] hard
i don't really act and i don't really go
in for this
type of stuff but we had this guy say a
rose fan of the show go
work on this audition me and ben worked
on the audition how many takes
five takes we did yeah it took us like
four days we nailed it we
nailed it nailed it and then that now
they're going to give the role to a
queen latifah
or someone else and that's okay
i've learned to live with disappointment
but it's sad because i thought i would
have been good in that picture
and there were other mega stars in that
picture and that was going to change
my life but sadly my life remains
completely unchanged
and that director's name was woody allen
woody allen woody allen
called me and said i want you to play a
role
in a movie i said what's the film about
he said it's about a man
who loves a girl
i said what it's about a man who loves a
girl
and he follows her home from school
every day
and he thinks about kidnapping her but
he doesn't kidnap her
it just ends up being really
quaint and cute and it's in new york
and instead of kidnapping her they
have coffee and listen to red scare
together in their house
and i was supposed to play a bus driver
that drove them around
and now and i can't do it now because
i'm not fat or old
enough enough fat enough it's not
amazing oh you're not
fat you're not fat enough i'm like i'm
fat enough to get the covered vaccine
yeah but we don't know could you get
fatter could you get
fatter and older could you get a little
closer to
death for the role i mean
i don't know what to i don't even know
what to think anymore about everything i
know the news
sucks everything's boring everybody that
grifted on politics is about to lose
their [ __ ] job
nobody cares about anything everybody's
upset
i brought rogan on the clubhouse the
other day historic
what's all these people mad that they
don't have a clubhouse invite
you can't find a way to get on clubhouse
i love what angers our society
people should have a right to be on
clubhouse they should also have health
insurance
what you know a clubhouse everybody that
wants to get on clubhouse could find a
way to get on club
it's not that [ __ ] hard but i brought
rogan on and it was a
very historic moment for that app and
then the founder of the app came on and
joe was kind of going right at him joe's
like
him you're gonna have trump on
the guy's like well that's a complex
question she was like ah you're scared
mom
not good man joe's like have you ever
been on oculus
did they talk about anything it should
be like vr mem
where people can see each other man they
can't see each other
it's not going mum i took a zinc uh
recently because he said it cured
coronavirus and i feel like i'm gonna
die
i feel like my stomach's exploding but
it was big and who was in the room joe
lex
uh eric weinstein brett weinstein red
wines the weinstein
family yes yes the traveling weinstein
brothers
lex friedman
uh leah uh the comedian
great yeah uh
naval ravikant oh naval yeah who is he i
don't know he has a lot of followers
though
what does he do i think he's like a big
tech guy is he i thought he was like
i thought he was like yeah like a guru
like i should like a sharper or a shaman
oh maybe
i looked him up on twitter he just has
nothing in the bio and he has like a
million followers
unimpressed yeah oh he's an
indian-american entrepreneur and
investor he's the co-founder and former
ceo of angel list
yeah me too who cares
take a seat take all the seats naval
everybody on club that's full of [ __ ]
everybody's fake
they're all entrepreneurs they don't
invest like i do
i'm a real investor i lose
that's what real investors do they lose
i went into [ __ ] amc heavy and i
lost 1800 that's what a real investor is
anyone can scam their way to a win
i lose honestly and go go
go in my backyard and curse dave portnoy
and scream and say [ __ ] your moth and
no one held the line and [ __ ] that guy
from robin hood
[ __ ] all these people that left me to
draw die on the [ __ ] beaches in
normandy
hold my dick and 2 000 shares worth of
shitty amc
stock worthless amc stock
last time i was in a movie theater i was
doing cocaine during the devil's rejects
like 2007. so it fat lines a blow at 3
p.m
i was the only one in the theater during
the mortgage crisis
just sitting there getting coked up
watching sid haig
i decided to blow money on that i go
that's coming back
and then i lost i lost all my [ __ ]
you know i lost 1800 and what are you
what are you gonna do
lucy nicotine is a company founded by
caltech scientists and former smokers
looking for a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative finally tobacco
alternatives that don't suck
researched and developed for three years
to be made for people not patients lucy
has created a nicotine gum with four
milligrams of nicotine that come in
three flavors winter green cinnamon
cinnamon and pomegranate lucy also has a
lozenge with four milligrams of nicotine
and cherry ice flavor each and every
flavor actually tastes great and it's
convenient and discreet
products can be enjoyed anywhere anytime
flights work
or on the go even in the gym i switched
to lucy products and i haven't had a
cigarette since
it's 20 21. get rid of your cigarettes
unplug your vape throw out your dip and
get some lucy [ __ ] ting gummy lazarus
this is the real deal the tim jill intro
listeners go to lucy.co and use promo
code tim get 20
off lucy.co promo code tim 20
off all products on your first order
including gum or lozenges
lucy.co promo code tim also i have to
give this disclaimer warning this
product contains nicotine derived from
tobacco nicotine is an addictive
chemical
you want to keep your hair folks this is
the reality you want to keep your hair
okay everybody loves it we're all trying
it i'm trying to keep the hair hair loss
is happening and people's
hair is receding two out of three men
will experience some type of hair loss
by the time they're 35.
more than 50 million men in the u.s
suffer from male pattern baldness there
are only two fda approved medications
that can prevent hair loss keeps orphans
both
i'm telling you it's a simple stress
free way to keep your hair convenient
virtual doctor consultations and
medications delivered straight to your
door
every three months you don't have to
leave your home low-cost treatment
started
as low as ten dollars per month keeps
offers generic versions of all the big
ones that everyone else does
discreet packaging and proven results
keebs has more five-star reviews than
any of its competitors
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months to see results who
act fast
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
tim dillon to receive your first month
of treatment for free that's keeps.com
tim dillon to get your first month for
free keeps.com k-e-e-p-s
dot com tim dylan great way to support
the show great way to keep your hair
so this documentary other than dylan
farrow on camera what else is in it
that's
really getting people heated because so
much of it seems
supposedly they have counselors and
other people who are witnesses to like
dylan's testimony please eric weinstein
be in this documentary
please god be in this documentary please
god how funny would that be please
god let the weinstein brothers be in the
woody allen documentary
please please let that be the vehicle
that jordan peterson comes back in
oh you know well you know it's the
it's the hero's journey you gotta you
gotta
slay the dragon and bring the gold back
to the village got to free your father
from the belly of the whale
please god please god let the
documentary be just the weinstein
brothers
telling dylan farrow she's a [ __ ]
i mean would that not be great can dylan
farrell go on the portal
would that not be the funniest thing in
the world
how old is dylan farah now let's see
she's a big chunky monkey is she
right we all have struggles with our
weight 35 now
my age
[Music]
and she's not a fan of the woodster no
so they have counselors saying what that
he's guilty yeah that like
she was confiding and the counselors and
uh i think like cps type people and
social workers and people that were like
investigating it at the time
that uh she was being molested yeah
in that video she said woody when she
was like seven years old that woody took
her up in the attic and was like oh
uh show me your private parts and let's
find her
bad doesn't look good
but some say she was coached right
that's the
what a sick thing if she was coached
what a sick woman mia pharaoh was
hi han ki come here
no we'll play with the dolls later
i want you to read this look into the
camera tell everybody what daddy did
i mean god if she was coached
mia farrow was a [ __ ] monster but i
mean it's
i mean i get well was this after sunyi
no well dylan was seven at the time so
this was
before suny right because i'm wondering
what would have made
woody like what would have made mia faro
that angry that she did this that she
coached her own daughter like there's
something crazy about
the idea of a parent coaching their own
daughter to say something so heinous
he must have been abusive towards her
perhaps i mean i guess but even in that
situation it's such a
[ __ ] thing to do you wonder if
i mean
and people have said this is going to
destroy you just blow his legacy to bits
yeah people have said that people it's
gonna blow his legacy to bits
he said he's done doa it's a tough thing
to watch
people have said it's hard to get
through people that have seen it
people say that you're really left with
no doubt
that it's a a real issue and that he's
incredibly guilty
it's coming out tomorrow really yeah
21st where where is it going to be hbo
pm eastern standard time
wow we'll see 9 p.m eastern standard
time on hbo
it's going to drop yep
i mean listen it is a very very
difficult subject that we obviously kid
around about
because what are we going to do but it
is one of those things where
it it makes you look very differently
at this guy who we've all you know
rightly believed was a genius a comedic
genius whose movies were absolutely
amazing
and uh this is going to be
pretty tough to dismiss
i mean he wrote an article where he
basically claimed total innocence and
said that this
matter had been settled um
this is crazy what's it called
do we know what it's called allen versus
pharaoh allen versus far and then
they're gonna bring out all the
the people that knew about this yep
i'm still mad at him for saying he's
gonna put me in a movie
and then not doing it
the director goes we're gonna cast
someone else can you believe that
we're gonna cast someone else
i mean that's absurd
i should be the whole movie you should
throw the script out
and you should follow me around for two
hours
summer blockbuster that's what it should
be
the whole movie should be me and dylan
farrow
just shooting the [ __ ] come on the show
she's more than welcome to come on the
show
i don't want to hear about the the get
in touch [ __ ] that's depressing but if
she's got anything else to talk about
her brands or products she's interested
in or investments
we'd love to have her on dylan you could
come on and talk about bitcoin
but don't depress everybody with the
molestation we're over that
so if you want to come on and talk about
cryptos where you see yourself how
you're positioned in the market
how to build the brand what post covid
looks like in terms of running the cap
table and getting really serious about
investing
we'll have you on but the minute you
open your mouth and you start throwing
throwing dirt on woody's name you're out
of here
we'll bleep you out well we'll bleep
the [ __ ] out of you if you throw dirt on
that man's name and don't [ __ ] on
kendall jenner either
not on this show you come here you talk
bitcoin or you talk
food
talk about some clam strips don't talk
about your clam strip
now many people feel this is insensitive
to victims of molestation and i
am not making fun of anyone who's
experienced molestation
i'm saying that as a child i wanted to
be molested
yes and no one molested me and this is
like a hack joke like
oh no one [ __ ] me up priest never
[ __ ] me but i
literally would stand in church with my
[ __ ] open
and no one [ __ ] me
my parents would let me do it they'd go
go down to the rectory and spread your
ass
and i wouldn't then i'd come home and
they'd go and i bet no one [ __ ] you
and i went
no and they went see like [ __ ]
um yeah it's a very tough topic and it's
not one that you can easily
joke around about even though we have
done that for 45 minutes
it's a it's a tough one i think that we
need a resolution
here we need to just move on why doesn't
bruce springsteen do a jeep commercial
about the
woody allen rape america's strength is
in the middle
dylan no matter what happened and woody
no matter what happened
america's strengths in the middle we
need to you both need to come together
america's strength is down the center
i'm going to go crash my car i'm a big
truck
how do i love that he got a dewey yeah
they redacted like 24 pages of that
they're trying to
make it public what he's doing yeah but
it's still like under investigation so
i imagine there's some very embarrassing
stuff in there well he said some racist
[ __ ] i'm sure
i know he's all like you know mr
progressive but you know when
when he got pulled over where do you get
pulled over we don't know but oh
i don't know if we know if they pulled
him over on a garden state parkway he
said a few things
don't you know who i am i'm the boss
i'm a white man how great would that be
if bruce springsteen just
the transcript he's screaming i'm a
white man born in the usa
i'm a what i mean
it's amazing jeep went through with that
commercial despite in november him
having this they don't care people like
people it's better
people enjoy it people want their
celebrities to get drunk
and get crash cars they don't care if
you're buying a dream grand cherokee
if you're buying imagine buying a jeep
grand cherokee
if you're buying a jeep grand cherokee
as brilliantly nick mullen said
it's for jarhead like retards who come
back from the war with flashbacks
if you're buying a jeep grand cherokee
you don't care that bruce springsteen's
a drunk
or that woody allen raped his kid
doesn't matter to you what's a product
it would go through with woody allen
even though he's
dylan's coming out with his dock what's
a product that would go go through with
woody allen no matter like
they wouldn't care i'm trying to think a
product that would just people wouldn't
they wouldn't be affected by it because
jeep doesn't care about
drunk bruce springsteen what product
would get behind pedo woody allen
like four loko maybe no
too ethnic you'd have to have something
kind of classy
like yoplait like yo play yogurt
yeah you know just a neurotic woody
allen being like i don't know
i don't even eat but yeah i like cow
play they go and they're in the
boardroom they're like
listen our yogurt is for like french
pedophiles who cares
in the same way that jeep was like our
cars are for people that are drunk
while buying the car it's for people
that are trying to
drink their traumas to the back of their
[ __ ] head
i think the ceo jeep gives a [ __ ]
uh a bob
bad news bruce just got popped on the
garden state parkway they got him on
they popped him on the turnpike and he's
screaming sandy n word
he goes good release that we'll use that
as a commercial
they originally wanted bruce drunk
screaming the n-word as the jeep
commercial
but they had to do that other horse [ __ ]
he goes that's good
i want to see bloated bruce springsteen
get thrown in the back of a cruiser
and then the jeeps just sitting there
and they go nobody stops the boss
from the reports that emerged the
officer allegedly observed springsteen
consuming what appeared to be alcohol in
the park and then starting up his
motorcycle
oh he was on a motorcycle that's great
next time drive a jeep
the lawyer says it might look like a
shot of tequila but who knows what it
was it might have been a shot of
gatorade
i swear to god that's like a direct
quote that's a real jersey lawyer
he's being represented by some real
jersey lawyer
the same guy representing woody allen
hey it might look like a kid saying that
uh
they got [ __ ] up in the attic but we
it might be a kid playing a
prank might also be a kid playing games
you know how kids do it's a shot of
gatorade
i mean what what a country all of our
heroes are collapsing in front of us
folks they're collapsing
there's nothing left to do except
embrace the mediocrity and the horror
that will come with people that don't
make
moral that aren't bad like that don't
rape and
maim and murder and kill
you know just let mr beast curate the
country
yes just let mr beast feed us
let mr beast decide what the art's gonna
be
just let nerds do it i'm not saying he's
a nerd but he probably is
probably just let autists do everything
now
just let people that can't say hello to
you run the world
they can't shake a hand or look in
anyone's eye they can't rape anyone they
can't even say hello
i feel bad man i feel bad for kendall
jenner
it's a rough week for kendall jenner and
for woody allen
and that's why they should shack the
[ __ ] up
you should be eating her [ __ ] at boa's
steakhouse
in sombreros she should come out in a
sombrero
dude kendall jenner if if i was kendall
jenner's pr person
which shockingly i'm not i would tell
her go out there and just
pose in front of an ice camp with your
tequila
remember the pepsi commercial that one
of them did i think it was kendall or
kylie
yeah it was kind of like give the cop a
pepsi how about pouring a shot for an
ice agent
how about porno shot of your tequila for
an ice agent then he takes it and he
goes
and opens the cage and all the kids come
out and they start dancing
why not
this this hotel is gonna [ __ ] us up man
yeah i hope they don't see this
what can they do after the fact
we could say these are uh like for the
stage these are like broadway cigarettes
i don't see any no smoking
yeah ed we're not setting off the fire
larva no one said no smoking
you know are we really doing
the wrong thing here i don't think so we
have to record ads
oh my god yeah it's so late
for the folks listening uh the episode
should have been out a couple hours ago
but i'll get it up in about five hours
then just flew into boston how was that
flight
it wasn't bad wasn't bad you're sitting
next to dylan farrow
run in her mouth god
the last thing you want to do is sit
next to her i'm kidding i feel bad i
don't know what to do
what am i supposed to do
am i supposed to really get out here and
take a side i don't have any of the
facts
i don't know if mexicans really make
tequila
it seems like they do but maybe kendall
jenner isn't mexican
her father's now her mother
oh she's armenian actually
i don't even know i mean i don't even
know what's their drink
they don't really have one right so you
gotta you gotta she's gotta do what
she's gotta do
i i i don't care
i i don't care that the kardashian
family
kim and kanye are divorced yeah they
make noise these people that's what they
do
they're they court controversy they're
they're important figures
in our lives and every now and then
they're gonna
do something wacky just like woody allen
these people and bruce they're gonna
drive drunk
i don't know what to tell you you know
i didn't do it i just lived through a
snowstorm
i just looked through the the icing over
of texas
ted cruz should start flaming kendall
jenner on twitter going you're a
[ __ ] culturally appropriating [ __ ]
stay out of my state keep your hands
off the real mexican tequila
i don't know it's very late here we got
to go to bed we got to record ads we got
it we got to prosper
we've got lots of shows coming up i
don't know where they are they're on a
website or
the guy who ran it quit we got to find
someone else what are you gonna do
but that's okay we're we're evolving
you know i will be in woody's new film
yep i will do it chalamet won't do it
that that strange bird-like guy
i'll do it shalom is like a little weird
mollusk shaolin made something that
should
sit on a shellfish tower i want to put
him on a thing of ice
and just dunk him into sauces and eat
him
what's wrong with that that's not
that's not rapey i mean consensually i
would ask him i'd go
yes cocktail or the spicy
uh calabrian chili mayo
mignonettes put them in the oyster sauce
yeah yeah
and let army hammer back in who cares
he wants to eat someone's heart it's all
fantasy so you know what i mean
new new movie new movie idea
new movie idea me army hammer
bruce springsteen kendall jenner
directed by woody allen there we go
there it is there it is
everyone's happy everyone's happy
we all move on great art will save us
what if woody made a really good movie
about him being in love with a
seven-year-old
but it was really funny like truly funny
we are not going to be on youtube in a
week
this will be it i know this will be it
soon
soon it's coming they better make room
at spotify joe you better
call someone i'm going to call someone
at spotify immediately
this that this where this podcast is
going to be exclusive to clubhouse very
soon if this keeps going on
but what if woody made a very funny
movie it's just like him
and a seven-year-old and he's like never
she nervous
is it like a comedy like daddy daycare
except it's a relationship no it's a
it's an intellectual rom-com
where he falls in love with a literal
child
and they walk around new york city is
that so
if it's really funny but if it's good
i'm saying
if it's good not half ass sure
good punch punch punch punch
laugh laugh laugh laugh boom bam boom
bam
quick smart
writing you know
he takes it to rome
ben's ben's nervousness that tesla get
repossessed
they say that's why you should have
bought out right like i did i'll live in
that range rover
in that whataburger parking lot [ __ ]
that guy but yeah would he just go into
rome
with the seven year old and bruce makes
it
record solve it love is whatever
it means love is beautiful
no matter what don't listen to mia
pharaoh she's some kind of chinese
don't listen to covert nineteen
what if woody allen just goes nuts and
starts screaming it was made in a lab
which is not nuts
but just being funny if that's his his
rebuttal his rebuttal to this is that
which covert 19 was made in the lab
all right folks go away
first of all we're only in this [ __ ]
dump
because the the last hotel we're at we
we couldn't get a a room that was bright
enough to record a podcast it was a real
problem
and dan knows what happened that's why
we've brought him here
to discuss it yeah so we try to check
into this other hotel which
will not be named and uh that was the
harbor hotel in boston the boston harbor
hotel
so yeah we're walking in we're trying to
check in and tim goes in he has a list
of demands because we are trying to get
this podcast recorded he goes in he's
like
all right i need a room that's big i
need a big table
i need a big desk i need i need a
terrace
he's like i need a helicopter pad
correct it's a huge list of demands you
know he said i need a butler
i need silver plates correct beautiful
china
and uh they're like okay well actually
you know we have a room that could
accommodate some of your needs
and uh we'll just take your card and so
he hands uh you you hand them
your your credit card i hand them the
credit card they had discussed the
presidential suite i thought that was a
bit too much
but i thought that we should stop short
of the presidential suite but be in that
area
i'm glad that was being discussed yeah
so he hands them the card
and uh what happens well i handed them
the card and it was declined yeah the
card gets declined
and because i don't have money on the
card
and this is the problem that these
people don't understand real
wealthy people don't have money i mean
this man goes in with like
demands yeah like a real list of bands
he's like i
i need i need luxury i yes i do but
my thing is i'll call my bank and get my
limit raised
if we are doing business but i need to
charge my phone
the card the card just keeps getting
declined and they're like they're like
sir
do you have do you have two thousand
dollars in there
what can we run it through for they're
like do you have proof that you have one
hundred dollars
do you have any money right now that we
can authorize on the card
i said i have to call my bank but my
phone is dead yeah so you had to charge
your phone
let me charge my phone and also how many
square foot is the room we're discussing
and this is the thing you know
i look like a crackhead yeah
but at the end and i'm we're right we
finally got the money we finally got the
money
and we went to see the room and we said
no good
and we went to check in and then we came
back down and we said we need all the
money back
it looks like the money back it looked
like you won it it looked like you got
embarrassed
like that you were like oh [ __ ] like i
don't have the money now i need to prove
that i have the money
maybe i'll call in some favors and then
we got there and we're like
you know what let's find an excuse on
why the room wasn't good enough we come
downstairs we go the room
is not well lit we need more light
because we're recording a podcast
which they don't even understand nothing
screams poverty more than we need
the room to record a podcast and also we
need
we need more light like it was a very
it was a very odd but by the way i
wasn't impressed with the room i didn't
like it i didn't think it was worth the
money and i laughed
and now we're hearing the wind in this
[ __ ] dump
it's disgusting well what have you done
for us
did you throw any of your cards did you
take any of your cards out
i did i i i brought your phone to the
concierge to let it charge
and i believe that my phone was used to
uh raise the credit limit
on the your bank was used to enter your
your phone was used to call the bank and
talk about and
enter into a negotiation about raising
capital people don't know that i'm
actually
uh partially a financier of this this
whole operation
how is how are you a financier well my
phone was used to help
finance yes uh the recording of this
podcast you don't spend any money
no we go on the road you spend zero
dollars i spend zero dollars and then
you're paid
well i'm paid i'm paid pretty well yeah
pretty well pretty well pretty well i
would say well
very well pretty well i'll say very well
pretty well is good pretty's good
pretty's accomplished pretty well is
good
you're probably i think you're paid very
well very well i agree i think you're
paid very well i'm not ungrateful
well that's very that's very nice but
what you're what you don't understand is
that what i'm doing is negotiating
and there are tactics when you negotiate
and one of the tactics is to not
have money and to keep everyone guessing
because anyone can throw out a credit
card and have a high limit and get
it approved but when people are guessing
and there's chaos introduced
you now see an opening so what i do is i
throw out a bunch of cards people start
going i get on the phone
people don't know what's happening at
the end of the day i get what i want i
feel like we look like two guys who just
walked in the hotel to shoot up
but we wanted to do it in like a fancy
area we had to get a credit card like no
raise no one thought we didn't go up to
that room and either like
suck off a homeless guy or do a bunch of
heroin and leaves yeah cause we
immediately
we were up there for maybe 10 to 15.
what a great idea two guys were like
we gotta shoot up we will only do it in
a suite
with two rooms and a balcony
yeah like the idea of the two guys
shooting up and going you know what we
need
more than just a bathroom we need a
suite this goes out to all the drug
addicts out there like you don't need to
go to the red roof inn or the days inn
or the motel 8 or whatever you can get
the presidential suite at the boston
harbor hotel
and then leave and then leave leave go
up
do whatever you need to do have your
abortion let them pull it out of you
go down and then say the room was not
well lit
yeah you don't need to do this in
poverty anymore you know in in
they when they walked up there nobody
thought
like everybody was like that was this we
pulled some scam yes but it was legit we
couldn't
use the room but they thought they were
gonna walk in there and just see
fetuses yeah i mean your phone's not
charged like oh these guys probably been
walking around
all day they thought the maid was going
to open it up and it just
fetuses still attached to the umbilical
cords just hanging
from the ceiling like you know that
scene for freddie got fingers daddy did
you want some sausages
daddy would you like some sausage just
fetuses that's what they thought
and drugged up fetuses as well i know
well all right
listen tell everyone where to find you
guys follow me at dan man carney
don't if you can thank you don't he
doesn't deserve it
i do deserve it make him earn it
all right [ __ ] make me earn it but
you know give me a follow what's what's
the what's the problem here
follow him and then yeah the same way
that we walked into that room and left
yes follow him and then unfollow him and
shoot heroin in luxury
oh of course and have your abortions at
the boston harbor hotel
they allow it